sur 57 hectares à la périphérie de
toulouse tout une véritable ville de
l'espace 2500 salariés y travaillent 60
% sont des cadres en 1968 la pose de la
première pierre du centre spatial de
toulouse répondait à toutes une volonté
de décentralisation impulsée par le
général de gaulle et sur laquelle le
ministre charbonnel ne manquez pas
d'insister lors de l'inauguration
officielle le 29 octobre 1973 nous avons
affaire ici à une opération de
décentralisation
quelques années plus tôt le 26 octobre
1965 la fusée diamant décoller dana gear
dans le sahara algérien pour mettre sur
orbite deux satellites astérix la france
venait de conquérir son billet ton
l'espace et de réaffirmer sa volonté de
ne pas laisser la route des étoiles au
seul soviétique américain le cnes centre
national d'études spatiales et est
implantée depuis 1962 à brétigny dans la
périphérie de paris
en décidant de la délocalisation de ses
activités techniques vers toulouse
le comité interministériel du 31 juillet
1963 s'appuyer sur la tradition
aéronautique de cette ville et sur le
pôle d'excellence en train de se
développer autour de l'université paul
sabatier un gros hic cependant le mot de
décentralisation faisait encore plus
peur qu'aujourd'hui parmi les
intelligentsia parisienne à l'imposer à
fait partie des jeunes ingénieurs qui
ont accepté de descendre à toulouse la
décentralisation ressembler à une
aventure une aventure à la fois
personnelles puisque pour beaucoup
d'entre nous les conjoints ou la famille
était impliquée fortement
et puis laventure professionnels aussi
parce que à l'époque des inquiétudes sur
l'avenir du cnes en termes de plan de
charge exister en raison en particulier
des difficultés budgétaires déjà de
l'époque donc environ la moitié des
personnels qui étaient en région
parisienne a préféré s'orienter vers nos
activités plutôt que de descendre dans
la ville rose dans cette cité tourner
vers les étoiles la passion ou 8 le rêve
à petite dose ou alors il faut qu'il est
un bon groupe propulseur capable de
lutter lancer des satellites
ce qui ne suit pas le cas de la fusée au
repas dans les années 70 le cnef alors
sorti tard yann de ses cartons des 30
ans du centre spatial de toulouse sont
ainsi fait de hauts et de bas il eut la
grande grève de 1976 12 sorties le
programme spot en 1995 le conseil de
l'espace européen tenu au capitole
viendra inquiéter les salariés
toulousains de nouveau rassuré par les
orientations de l'actuel gouvernement
qui ne souhaitent pas privilégier les
vols habités
aujourd'hui se pose un grand point
d'interrogation vis-à-vis de l'union
européenne quelle place peut dois t'y
prendre le cnes cette tête de pont
française de l'espace en europe